jetzt kann ich auf einmal wieder fliegen
die bank mit dem schlagen auf einmal
wieder der junge jetzt hab ich die waadt
mit dem schlagen auf einmal wiederkommen
aber das war die entscheidung das war
wirklich irgend ein fehler von mel ramos
das hatte ich schon verläuft okay ich
bin bereit
du bist bei von craft nee ich bin bereit
und brenne ich möchte hier die ansage
machen ich okay dann sag' herzlich
willkommen zum monday play conti auf
leeren magen
gleich wird und lose blätter zusammen
klappt es händen also ich soll jetzt die
ansage machen
okay was was was soll ich dann sagen man
der player ist ist es was wir machen
mann der welt
aber weil ich da irgendwie scheiße ich
habe selber probleme hatte ich bin vom
server geflogen warte ich konnte ich
komme wieder
zum glück kann wenn er nie angefangen
von finde ich auch bekommen wieder ich
komme ja seit dem 8 seid ihr noch da
ja aber du hast ja das ist wahr ich
geflogen bin ja leider ist die konfi
natürlich dann solltet ihr vielleicht
kommen leiden lassen
okay ich bin jetzt im dings in einem
spinnenweben links und irgendwie
ich hüpfe auch irgendwie du willst also
mit space taxis nicht das ist immer so
leicht gedrückt meine space taste mich
mal kurz das den komplett ja guck ich
hoffe ihn die ganze zeit ich drücke
meine space taste nicht normal ist oder
gemeine ins bett ich drücke die nicht
ich bin im inventar wir müssen wir
müssen noch mal neu anrufen kommen wir
neuen rufen kommen wir neu anrufen
ja okay gut sondern machen ja jetzt geht
dass wir eine reihe januar aber mich
haben und zwar ich hab die ganze zeit in
minecraft ich kann nicht aufhören
ja danke aber das bringt auch nicht wenn
ich gleich bauen muss und die ganze drum
hüpfe ergebnis inventar das archiv das
mich orten wenn traten auf die latten
auf shift und auf die leertaste bringt
nichts was also richtig machst dir vor
es gehört
so macht er seine tante gebracht ich
springe einfach mal mit es geht wirklich
nur noch anschlagen komme die allawi wir
starten
wer wirklich ich bin wirklich nur noch
anschlagen was ist los bei minecraft ist
ein konzept das ist nicht mein ohne witz
alter ich will am liebsten sofort essen
gehen ich will jetzt einfach aufnehmen
aber ich weiß nicht wer aber wenn ich
doch schlage dann heute doch immer
wieder den wirklich kaputt oder aber
nochmal auf die tastatur eigene taste
wetter wollte ich einfach nochmal in
seoul hatte tasten drauf haben alles
drauf gedrückt alles die einfach aber
vom server und das spiel durch die
tollste grade ich trolle nicht alter ich
schwöre auf mein leben noch ja geholt er
hat erster schlepper aufnahme oder ich
nehme jetzt geht es auch wenn ich am
aufnehmen ich bin ich im aufnehmen so
fernab alter ok und hits gehabt alles
klappt alles okay dann durchstarten ich
noch mal ihr seid ihr bereit und wenn
ich gern bereit
mach das doch jetzt eben drei glücklich
ist
jetzt kann ich auf einmal wieder fliegen
dem schlagen auf einmal wieder der junge
geschlagen auf einmal wiederkommen
meine aufnehmen
walter nein nein com bewahrte ganz
gedeutet wird man hier komme ich bin aus
ich kann ich kann nichts kaputt machen
ganz weit oben siehst du aber ich bin
die ganze zeit angeschlagen und ihr hört
ja ich bin nicht am drücken
ich drücke nicht das ist so komisch aber
was hast du vorhin gemacht damit das
aufhört einfach auf die tastatur hauen
einfach irgendwas hier ist auch mal die
faust gegen die wand bitte ja es geht ja
es geht es geht es geht ja du bist ein
arschloch kleinen spaß
nein danach kannst du dir jetzt mach ich
wirklich die ansage jungs aber dass man
das war wirklich irgend ein fehler von
mir damals hatte ich schon verläuft so
okay aber weiterhin auch so viel kaputt
wer macht das dann immer alles kaputt
ihr ja dann auch beim brunnen so viel
sonst ok combos wird startet ja ich
mache den brunnen wieder heile ja gut
ach so ja eben was bei mir
wir können starten 32 oder jung meine
verbindung ist weg die agenda21 server
landet plötzlich weg mit ansage
minecraft spieler nicht essen gehen ja
gut was euch sagen ich mache die ansage
dass die anlagen am 13 21